superior Spider-Man kills Spider-Man and
it's amazing check this out so in Marvel
Comics there's a story called Spider-Man
dying wish and what we end up learning
in the events leading up to that story
is that Dr Octopus is basically dying so
in a last-ditch effort to save his life
he basically has a kind of device
attached to Peter Parker which forces
them to switch bodies the mind of Peter
Parker goes into the body of Dr Octopus
and the mind of Dr Octopus goes into the
body of Peter Parker following that Dr
Octopus becomes The Superior Spider-Man
and while the consciousness of Peter
Parker at least a fragment stays behind
ultimately Dr Octopus ends up killing it
off and he goes forward as a straight up
villain punching people's Jaws off their
faces and realizing Spider-Man could
have beat them to death at any point in
time ultimately he turns over a new Leaf
he becomes a good guy and that in The
Superior Spider-Man story make sure you
guys check the link in the comments for
the full video